[Music]
oh
better put five cents in the meter no
policeman is going to give the batmobile
a ticket
no matter robin this money goes toward
building better roads we all must do our
part
good citizenship you know
holy taxation you're right again batman
the parking meter that much maligned
regulator of city streets celebrates its
87th birthday today
back in the 1930s automobiles were
filling city streets overrunning many
central business districts including
downtown oklahoma city elizabeth bass is
with the oklahoma historical society in
1913 there were only 3 000 registered
automobiles in oklahoma by 1930 there
were 550 000 so there needed to be a way
to monitor how long people were staying
and parking in front of their businesses
to solve the problem the oklahoma city
chamber of commerce turned to local
newspaper man carl mcgee
he had an idea for a timing device and
recruited two engineering professors at
oklahoma a m to design and build it so
on july 16th 1935 the world's first
parking meter was installed on what was
then the corner of 1st street and
robinson avenue in downtown oklahoma
city oklahoma city believes it has
solved the parking problem with a meter
that charges five cents to allow you to
park in a certain place for one hour you
set the dial and it ticks off the
minutes
despite the instant resistance with many
seeing the invention as just another
form of taxation the meters would go on
to be a success
starting a revolution that would spread
around the globe remarkably carnegie's
basic design and mechanics wouldn't
change much over the next seven decades
until the turn of the century when
cities and towns turned to machines
operated by credit card and lately even
cell phone apps even here in oklahoma
city of course parking meters also led
to another unwelcome innovation the
parking ticket the first person who
received a fine for putting not putting
money in the meters was actually a
pentecostal minister who left his car
and uh went into a shop to get changed
to get a nickel to put it in the meter
and by the time he came back out there
was a ticket on his car that was the
first person who actually got a ticket i
was going to say even god can't save you
from parking tickets exactly
and it's it's fascinating when you see
who's connected to history this car
mcgee character look him up online if if
you have the time he was connected to
the teapot dome scandal a major piece of
american history and he was accused of
manslaughter at one point before he
became a newspaper man got to oklahoma
and uh you know was part of the team
that put the parking meter together so
who would have thought i i will say i
had a hard time with parking tickets in
ann arbor oh i got my money eventually i
stacked them up that's right not a fan